[Music]
Harry Styles and Emily radakowski
spotted kissing we've been doing all
this late night
[Music]
the singer was caught making out with
the actress in multiple videos
circulating online and it all went down
in Tokyo the latest stop on his level
into her concert series I don't know
look at us too he's roaming the streets
stuff this comes nearly five months
after Harry split from his ex Olivia
Wilde and almost seven months after
emrata filed for divorce from estranged
husband Sebastian bear McLeod who she
shares two-year-old son Sylvester I'm
just interested in keeping you safe and
happy
the actress has most recently been
linked to Pete Davidson Brad Pitt and
Eric Andre and now fans are reacting to
this resurface clip hosted by the not
skinny but fat podcast where it seems
Harry manifested their moment
celebrity crushed Emily Ryan
[Music]
with Harry and Emily's makeout session
making its rounds some are speculating
how serious things are between the two
people wanted to know on a recent
episode of Emily's high low podcast she
admits what she's currently looking for
when it comes to dating I'm newly single
I'm like I don't know if I ever want a
relationship again yeah and it's
something Emily echoed in an interview
with variety back in October quote I'm
newly single for basically the first
time in my life ever and I just feel
like I'm kind of enjoying the freedom of
not being super worried about how I'm
being perceived I think that you know
just in general now being someone who's
in the public eye and has experienced
that so much I really encourage people
to have a healthy
um
a little bit of disbelief of and and
wanting you know and just understand
that these these headlines are designed
for people to click on them essentially
only time will tell if the pair's
romance progresses but safe to say their
love lives are definitely
as it was
[Music]